mon président mon endroit brésil -
président retour de notre moi président
tour
pour ce deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles l'occasion pour nous de
revenir avec la question du moment
et si vous étiez candidat à l'élection
qu'auriez vous dit pour convaincre les
électeurs
mais cette fois-ci l'exercice devient un
peu plus corsée avec un thème imposé à
case-pilote face à la stèle célébrons
l'arrivée des indiens en martinique en
1853 nous trouvons rapidement le thème
du jour l'immigration parce que c'est un
thème de campagne qui venus souvent sur
le tapis alors qu'en dites vous si vous
bloquez c'est pour empêcher d'autres et
c'est là le problème
vous n'allez pas de jalousie vis-à-vis
de ça je la tiens fait pourtant les
questions de droit d'asile de quotas
d'immigration de contrôle des frontières
d'intégration de l'identité ont
régulièrement été abordés devenant même
pour certains l'une des principales
promesses de campagne avec pour credo
retrouver les frontières nationales
moi j'ai pas de problème avec
l'immigration en général mais c'est vrai
que ça devient de plus en plus difficile
d'accepter les gens sur le territoire
déjà qui a pas beaucoup de pain pour les
français et donner aux autres je peux
comprendre que certains ça peut gêner
par rapport à ce principe
actuellement en étant valley on
intervalles et les enfants ne trouvent
pas de travail vont à l'extérieur et on
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème on va
aider les autres on va aider haïti on va
et et sainte-lucie on va aider dominé
caen fait même des écoles alors qui a
rien pour les jeunes
alors il faut avoir une vraie politique
de l'immigration la seconde personne
mais je dis d'abord on s'occupe de nous
avant et bien pour information le taux
d'immigration en martinique n'est que de
2%
[Musique]
moi j'aurais déjà évité de faire peur à
l'électorat parce qu'il faudrait deux
sets dire que tous les problèmes
français viennent de l'étranger
c'est pas un des problèmes principaux je
pense qu'on ne parle pas d'écologie on
parle pas d'eux ne parle pas du handicap
en france il ya certains français même
qui commande et rush qui veulent pas
faire certains travaux
ils sont bien contents d'aller trouver
les niveaux si toutes ces questions
mettent des candidats dans l'embarras
pour d'autres les réponses sont très
claires marine le pen propose un
durcissement en bloquant les frontières
nationales
emmanuel macron lui misé sur une
collaboration européenne
voilà c'est dit prochaine étape de notre
tour des communes le morne vert petite
commune paisible où il sera question des
retraites - président
bah